>> Sasha Dowdy: Good
afternoon, everyone.
I hope you all had a good lunch.
Doing great.
So welcome to the Library of
Congress National Book Festival.
My name is Sasha Dowdy,
I work at the Library
of Congress Young
Readers' Center,
which is a really special place
in the Library of Congress
for kids, teens,
and their families.
For everybody who's
under 16 years old.
And you can come take a
look into the millions
of collections at the library.
The Library of Congress National
Book Festival recognizes
and celebrates the importance of
reading and authors and books.
The Library of Congress makes it
seem easy to do this every year,
but the truth is the library
festival is a huge undertaking.
It's a huge financial
undertaking and it is free
for everyone because
of the generous support
from our sponsors
and supporters.
Spread the joy of reading
with your gift online
on LOC.gov/donate,
from the Festival app,
or when you purchase
books today.
And now onto the main event.
We have here author
Russell Ginns!
[ Applause ]
When I was reading a
little bit about him,
I realized that he is a very
unique author whose books
and works can be found
everywhere in the library.
So he's a game designer.
So they can be found in the
movie and game division.
And he's also a composer,
so you can find music
in our performing arts library.
And he is a puzzle maker.
And those things you
can find anywhere
within our 167 million
item collection.
And I challenge you
guys to come find them.
And of course, Russell
writes books.
He's written over 100 books.
They are fun, they're smart,
and they're full of adventure.
So buckle in, and you're
going to find out more about
"Samantha Spinner and
the Super Secret Plans."
It's a spectacular journey
through Seattle, Washington,
Paris, and other countries and
cities that I won't tell you
about because they're
super secret.
So, welcome Russell
Ginns, everybody!
[ Applause ]
>> Russell Ginns: Testing, okay!
Well, thank you guys.
It is a huge thrill to
be at the book festival.
So I want to start
by saying thank you.
I'm probably going to say
thank you a couple times.
And I am here to talk to
you about my new book series
"Samantha Spinner and
the Super Secret Plans."
Where Samantha's
uncle disappeared.
But before he took
off, he taught Samantha
and her brother how to
say please, thank you,
and "where's the
tallest building?"
in 11 different languages.
And they set off to find
them and they discover
that no place is in
the middle of nowhere.
>> [Singing] Samantha Spinner!
And the Super Secret Plans!
Samantha Spinner!
Going to Egypt, going to
France, looking for the man
in the green plaid pants!
Sam Spinner!
And the Super Secret Plans!
[ Music ]
[Singing] Going to Egypt, going
to France, looking for the man
in the green plaid pants!
Sam Spinner!
And the Super Secret Plans!
[ Applause ]
>> Russell Ginns: When
I was about your age,
my parents took me to see a
play in a big fancy theatre
and I got a little bit bored.
And I started looking around
at the space in the theatre,
the walls, and I started
thinking all those shapes,
do any of them do anything?
And I started thinking wow,
what if one of them
was a secret panel?
And you could open a
rectangle and go up a ladder
that nobody else knew about?
And you went up a
secret staircase
and there was a room at the top?
And I took that idea
and I thought
about that all over the place.
So I would see this lion
sculpture in front of a laborer
and I would think wow, what
if you could pull its tail
and it opened up
a panel that went
to a secret underground subway.
And there are these buttons
on the sides of buildings
and I thought wow, what if some
of them are underground
monorail controls?
And then I saw this bank in
New York and it had shields
around the top of the building.
And I thought wow, what
if you could pry them open
and they were the entrance to a
crazy straw that zipped you off
to Germany or zipped
you off to France?
And then there's this
diamond in the Smithsonian.
Have you ever heard
of the Hope diamond?
So well, what if that
in there is a fake?
It's a piece of glass?
And the real Hope diamond
is out there somewhere,
maybe it's around a dog collar.
And the owners don't
know it yet.
And so I took all of those ideas
and I put it into my book series
"Samantha Spinner and
the Super Secret Plans."
And I started the
story in Seattle,
Washington because that's
where I was living at the time.
And I'll talk a little bit about
that later, but it's always good
to write about what you know.
And in my story,
Samantha has an Uncle Paul
who only wore green plaid
pajamas all day everyday
and bright orange flip flops.
But then he disappeared,
and he left behind presents
for his nieces and nephews.
And Samantha's older sister gets
a check for 2.4 billion dollars.
And a note that says
"Have fun shopping!"
And her brother gets the
deed to Yankee stadium
and all the players' contracts.
So he's the new owner
of the New York Yankees.
And he has a note that
comes with it that says
"Don't miss opening day!"
And Samantha, she gets
an old rusty umbrella
with a hole in it.
And a note that says
"Watch out for the rain."
So if you read my book,
and I hope you do,
the title of chapter
2 is "It Wasn't Fair."
And it really didn't seem fair
at all but one thing leads
to another and they look at
the inside of the umbrella
with a magnifying
glass and they discover
that it's actually got secret
drawings and maps and plans
to all kinds of secret
passageways
that take you all
over the world.
And so starting in book
one and then onward,
they go to countries,
some you've heard of,
some you haven't heard
of, all around the world.
But you'll remember
that note that said
"Watch out for the rain"?
Well, of course, that
stands for the Royal Academy
of International Ninjas.
And they used to have
the super secret plans,
and used it to cause
crimes and break
into banks and art museums.
And they still do all that.
But now they have
to use the sewers.
So they become stink bandits.
And they smell terrible.
And they're really mad about it.
And they want the umbrella back.
And that is the start
of my book series,
and it takes you all
around the world.
And there's a question
people ask me all the time.
They say "Have you
ever been to Italy?
Have you ever been to Mali?"
And I say not yet.
They say "Have you
ever been to St Louis?"
Well, not yet.
And so how do you think I
write about all these things?
So, I don't know if other
authors are doing this
or did I invent this
or discover this?
But I've been using
Google Earth.
Do you guys all know
about Google Earth?
Yeah, so what I do is in
the section of the chapter
of my book, when I want
them to go some place,
I find it on Google
Earth, and then I zoom in
and I take it down
to street view.
And then I can see the scene
exactly the way my characters
Samantha and her
brother see the scene.
And so I'm going to read you
a little chapter of my book
where they're on the
streets of Florida,
I'm sorry, Florence, Italy.
And they have to go find
a statue because they know
if they find a statue of horses,
there's a secret
button inside one
of the nostrils of
one of the horses.
Samantha took a closer
look at the horses
from the edge of the pool.
They seemed to be
splashing and straining
as they hauled Neptune
through the water.
Their mouths were open
as if gasping for air.
She looked even closer
at the marble faces
and noticed a blue dot
in one horse's nostril.
"There's something up with that
horse," she told her brother.
"Follow me."
Water bubbled gently
around them as they splashed
through the water towards
the center of the pool.
They came face-to-face
with four,
bright white marble stallions.
Nipper squinted at the
horse for a moment,
then he stood up straight.
"Step aside!"
he said loudly, pushing
his sister out of the way.
He raised a hand in the air
and he wiggled an index finger.
"This is a nose-worthy
situation,
and I have been called upon
to use my special talent."
Samantha groaned.
"You are exceptionally gross."
Nipper plunged his finger deep
inside the horse's dark nostril
and pressed.
Something gave a little,
and there was a click,
followed by four,
loud creaking noises.
Somewhere below the street,
it sounded like four
giant toilets flushing.
She started to lose her footing.
The fountain had
become an angry storm.
"Wait!" she shouted.
"I just remembered there's
something that we-- ."
The current yanked
Samantha under the surface,
ending her sentence in
a gurgling "Wheeee!"
She was being sucked
towards a shape
in the front of the horses.
She flailed her arms, slapping
at the water helplessly,
and slid into the darkness.
[ Applause ]
So, I'm having a ton of
fun writing adventures
with Samantha and her brother.
Learning and exploring
places all around the world.
But I have also filled my book
with secret hidden
codes and puzzles.
Have ever of you guys
heard of an escape room?
You guys know about
escape rooms?
Well I went to one a while ago
and I thought wouldn't
it be cool
if you could turn a book series
into a secret escape room?
So there's word searches.
If you take the titles
of certain chapters
and you put them together,
they form a word search.
There's one character,
there's numbers at the bottom
of the page and they tell
you which words to read
and they'll direct you
to a secret website.
And if you go there,
it says "Stop!
Don't read Samantha Spinner,
it's a terrible book!
No one should read that!"
And there's all sorts
of puzzles and clues.
So just to give you an idea
of what I'm talking about
and how I do it, I put
a couple puzzles here.
Now, don't shout it out.
Samantha's umbrella hid
a lying, smelly ninja.
Take a closer look,
there's the name
of a country hidden in there...
Ah-ha! Okay, we'll do another.
I brought my lunch
in a paper bag today.
Take a closer look,
there's the name
of a country hidden
there somewhere!
Raise your hand if you
think you've got it.
China! Okay, we'll do one more.
Dennis, that's their dog,
saw a man in a cape
running in the street.
Don't shout it out.
There's a country
hidden there somewhere.
One, two, three.
I'll do another so you
can see another way
that I hide messages
in the book.
Iceland, Norway,
Denmark, Italy, Albania.
There's five countries,
now take a closer look.
The name of a secret
sixth country is hidden
there somewhere.
How'd you get it?
She said India.
Exactly. So that's one of
the things I've been doing.
The message behind my whole
book is that no place is
in the middle of nowhere.
That just because places seem
far away, it may seem strange
to you, they don't seem that way
to the people that live there.
My characters are fearless,
and they're exploring not just
famous places that you've heard
about some friend who
went to on vacation,
but countries all
over the world.
And let's see.
Okay, Peru.
Who can tell me which of these
animals you'd find in Peru?
The llama, yes.
That's a llama you'd find
in the Andes mountains.
That to the right is a
Komodo dragon, not in Peru.
Those only live in
islands off Indonesia.
And I thought it was really
funny when I started reading,
well not funny,
but an interesting thing
that could be funny.
In chapter two, my
second book in the series,
Samantha's brother
goes to Indonesia
and he sees a Komodo dragon.
And he sneaks it home
because he thinks he's found a
baby dinosaur.
And that part of the story
doesn't end very well.
But okay, we'll do another.
Oops. Let's try that again.
One more time.
Okay, who can tell me which of
these you'd find in the USA?
Yes? That's the leaning tower
of Pisa, that's in Italy.
Egypt? No, the pyramids?
Oh, the elephant.
Of course, that is
Lucy the Elephant,
found in Margate
City, New Jersey.
And the elephant shaped hotel.
And when I found out about
the elephant shaped hotel,
I got really excited.
And I decided I would make
the third book in my series,
which I'm just writing now,
all about important things
or amazing places you'd find
around the United States.
And so they go to the, the story
starts at the elephant hotel.
Then they go to Carhenge,
a monument that's
made out of old cars.
And they go to the corn palace
in Mitchell, South Dakota,
a building that's
covered with corn.
And then the rest of my series,
then they go back to Italy,
they go to around
countries in Africa.
They go to Russia.
They go to China.
And they, as I said
before, along the way,
they learn to say merci, xiexie,
grazie, dhanyavad, terima kasih,
[inaudible], choukrane, gracias,
domo arigato, [Russian],
and that all means....
>> Thank you.
>> Russell Ginns: And I'd
like to say thank you guys.
This is an amazing thrill,
to be able to come and talk
about my book with readers.
So I really appreciate it.
And the one thing I want
to do before we have time
for a question or two, I've
been collecting these things.
At the count of three,
will you guys all go
"Watch out for the rain!"
One, two, three.
>> Watch out for the rain!
>> Russell Ginns:
No, that's not it.
This is really important.
This is a matter
of life and death!
One, two, three!
>> Watch out for the rain!
>> Russell Ginns: Thank you.
>> [Singing] Samantha Spinner!
And the Super Secret Plans!
Samantha Spinner!
Going to Egypt, going to
France, looking for the man
in the green plaid pants!
Sam Spinner!
And the Super Secret Plans!
>> Russell Ginns: Thank you.
So time for one or two
questions before time's up?
Got two questions.
Over there.
>> How did you get the
idea for your books?
>> Russell Ginns: Well I got
the idea because I really
like the idea of seeing real
places and things all over,
and wow, what if there was
a secret passageway there?
And I had kids at the time who
were around your age and one
of them was reading the
Magic Treehouse and one
of them was reading
Captain Underpants.
And I thought wow, what if you
put the Magic Treehouse together
with Captain Underpants and
you'd have amazing adventures
that taught you about
real things in the world.
And that's where
I got that idea.
Next.
>> So what inspired you to read?
I mean to write books?
>> Russell Ginns: Well
I've always liked books
and storytelling
and song-writing.
And there's something
really special
about writing a whole
novel with characters
that you get attached to.
And so that's what I got
really excited about.
Wow, you could really
learn more about the world
and about real people in
the world through the eyes
of characters your age.
And that's what inspired me.
>> I was wondering if you have
a particular person or kind
of person in mind who
you're writing to.
Like do you picture your
reader as you write?
>> Russell Ginns:
I absolutely do.
I picture readers like you.
I even found a program on
an app called Voice Stream,
which reads your voice back.
Or your writing back in the
voice of a 10-year-old kid.
And I do that.
So whenever I write,
I write a chapter,
and then I have it
read back to me.
But I'm always thinking about
a 4th-grade boy or girl.
And especially one that has
a really annoying brother
or a really annoying sister.
Because you probably
can relate to that.
>> Where did you find
the book about Samantha.
Did you just make it up?
>> Russell Ginns: The name?
I'm sorry.
>> No, the book.
>> Russell Ginns: The book?
I'm sorry, I just
couldn't hear the question.
>> The name of the book.
>> The book about Samantha.
>> Russell Ginns:
Oh, why did I come
up "The Super Secret Plans?"
The title?
Because I love alliteration.
Do you know what
alliteration is?
Where you put sounds together?
And I don't even know where I
came up with the name Samantha.
But I knew that there
were secret plans.
And I thought well, they
could be super secret plans.
And then there could be
a girl named Samantha.
And then I just kept adding.
So it's Samantha Spinner
and the Super Secret Plans.
And then book two in my series,
which is just coming out.
It's called Samantha Spinner
and the Spectacular Specs.
Because I just want to keep
that going because it's fun.
Thanks. Do we have time for...
One more question!
Last question over here!
>> When did you start writing?
>> Russell Ginns: This book?
Well I've been writing
for a long time.
I started in magazines.
And then I'm going to
tell you something scary.
This is a scary story now,
this might even be horrifying.
I wrote this book, I started
writing this book almost ten
years ago!
And did any of you guys ever say
like "I'm going to do something"
and then you never finish it?
Yeah. That happened to me.
So I would always,
always be-- how you doing?
Good. Be careful, I don't want
you to fall off the stage.
So make sure you use the steps.
Alrighty. So-- I started
writing my story, no.
I think-- I started writing
my story about ten years ago.
And then I looked at a penny.
And I noticed somebody
changed the back of the penny.
And I thought whoa, I've got
to finish writing this book
or it's not going
to mean anything.
Okay, come on.
We gotta' go down.
Can somebody give me a hand?
Thank you.
I looked at the back of a
penny and they changed it.
And so I thought, well I've got
to finish this book really soon.
And then I got really serious.
And I wrote it in
about three months.
But that is just to
do a rough draft.
I don't know if other writers
or your teacher tell you
about writing is
about re-writing.
So I spent the next nine
months working with editors,
my mom looked at it, my
friends looked at it.
And it took about a
year to get the book
from when it was a rough
draft to what you see now.
So you've got to start writing
and you've got to
start re-writing.
But I think I'll stop here.
Because they're rushing
the stage.
Anyways, thank you very much.
This is just a huge thrill.
Thank you.
And-- . Okay.